my name was the only Nick Nick the
jeweler one of my clients sauce Walker
he's the one who gave me the name Iceman
Nick I steamed up I said everybody
What's Up G key oh this is Iceman Nick
custom jeweler out of Houston Texas aka
mr. Dunn right I'm gonna show y'all some
of my custom jewelry custom pendants
that have made if you don't hit it in by
Nick and you are watching on the rocks
out of these over here my favorite one
on this table I'll say the one recently
I did it for my boy Earl Spence this is
a Cuban link chain the links to these
links in the middle which are connected
between the Cubans these are called
infinity links right here
the Cuban link has baguettes in it and
then we have four Infinity links in the
middle that's why we gave this a name of
infinity Cuban link I put his name on
the lock arrows Spence jr. the piece is
his logo that's what he goes by man down
there's a man two men and one man is
down the other man you know hit him so
that's the logo right there man down all
together this setup was a four hundred
thousand this one of the most expensive
pieces this is 18 karat white gold this
piece has baguettes around the bezel the
center stone in this piercings in the
middle of the money bag as you can see
it's 2.5 carat G is certified internally
flawless yellow diamond if this diamond
was not a GIA certified it would be I
would say like $10,000 cheaper the
smaller yellow diamonds as you can see
on the letters and on the money bag
behind the center stone these are not
treated yellow diamonds these are
natural yellows you can see anybody they
use the yellow diamonds 99% are not
natural
this stone by self is $90,000 and the
whole piece he spent 200k on it the main
thing is he wanted it spinning you see
it spins the watch I like the most on
this table is the chandelier it's called
the brick AP the main thing about it is
it's God baguettes
done all the way every way that's why
they call it like a chandelier
it has baguette diamonds all the way
even in the inside the face the dial is
all baguettes 18 karat rose gold this
plane watch with no diamonds is 65,000
all the way i stuff like this
it's 200k Florida one said his
birthday's coming up he told me to just
one he's getting for his birthday this
is one of my clients I had done a piece
for a boozy I have everybody seen it lil
boosie's he liked that piece I made for
Busey so he sent me his picture he said
he wanted his piece done just like Busey
and he actually has these chains made
with Tom's do you see the guy wearing
the chains this guy actually has this
piece plus he has pieces he is wearing
on the piece he has those pieces also I
make pieces which have pieces talking
about the face pieces this is a picture
piece I'm making for Jada youngin and
it's not done yet
it's still like getting worked on but I
wanted to show this piece is because all
the detail work it goes in it it's not
just like a plain piece you know he has
raised so this piece is made in
different pieces like this is his
picture and this is the hairs and you
know that's how we put it together once
I'm gonna put it together after I'm
gonna ice it out this piece once it's
done it'll be 150,000 he had actually
got this piece made from another jeweler
which he didn't like the quality of work
of diamonds and and then that's why he
had me redo this piece he wanted to have
it done right and this is another
infinity chain this is Caspar he's under
the reggaeton artists this is his logos
it says los médicos and there's a Caspar
right there
he's gonna come pick it up next week too
I just got it ready all of these clients
Busey Flo Rida
all my clients I have long relationship
I mean doing business with them for like
over 15 years
yeah really like I would like to make
jewelry for Floyd Mayweather you got a
lot of pieces and you got a lot of money
so Floyd look what I can do
hit me up yeah you can say that this is
a sandy character as you can see I just
made it for nobody but I posted it on my
page Megan is telling she just hit me up
yesterday she was like I like that piece
you posted I want to get that one so
she's in town today so she's gonna come
get this one so I have done a lot of
jewelry for her I have done the baguette
chain for her I have done the Stella
piece you know probably have seen it
stly austerities I've done that for her
and I've just made some new pieces for
her right there it's a heart it's made
in rose gold it has enamel you can see
the ribs and it's actually one heart but
it's two pieces one is for Megan and the
other one is for her boyfriend money bag
yo she's gonna have tennis chains on it
nice size 10 is chains and this heart as
you can see is like enamel work done
right in the middle and then it has
diamonds going all the way she told me
she want a broken heart I got on the
designing right away and I sent her this
and she said she loved it she loved the
way I did the rips the heart broken and
you know and she loved it
I prefer using diamonds but sometimes
you have to do the enamel work in order
to you know it makes the piece the
lettering stand out or sometimes you
know we have to do that but like as in
this piece the enamel work isn't real
beautiful if it brings out the detail on
the piece and everything my client his
name is Bobby he got this logo and he
showed it to me he want this for his
piece it has letters Bobby's world in
enamel the rest we have the diamonds
pave setting all the way the diamond is
a real heavy piece it has almost 35
carats in diamonds this piece was $65
this is one of my favorite pieces so I
had asked him you know let me borrow it
for the show another one I call in Yoshi
this is one of my good friends he plays
for the Chicago Bears a football player
his name is Eddie Jackson this one has
like a dead enamel work on this too you
can see the hairs you can see the tongue
the eyes it has enamel even at the
bottom the shore it's a yellow bottom
and it's a real 3d solid piece solid
back it says Iceman Nick and if it don't
hit it in by Nick I love making
character pieces for my clients and
luckily I haven't had no issue with
copyrights yet this is they call it the
Brazilian Jesus you know they have this
in Brazil if they anybody has visited or
you know everybody has seen it on TV I
made this for one of my number one
clients busey this is the first
Brazilian Jesus I made and once I made
this for him like everybody made the
smaller version or they then started
selling them he wears it on a Cuban
chain and it hangs like this yeah it's
pretty heavy
this piece weighs almost a kilo it's
heavy and it has 50 carats in diamonds
all the way pave diamonds all wrong
diamonds at the time when I made this
piece for him
it'll called he had booze he had paid
120 for it 20 times I made this piece
like five years ago so definitely it's a
little bit more than what it was at that
time I don't think any of the
invest with the investment pieces the
custom pieces like that especially I
don't consider it like a like an
investment
I'll custom make you something anything
you want you love I can make it it's not
a problem but if you're looking for it
as an investment you have to go
somewhere else this one right here yeah
this is actually one of the most
expensive pieces it's a Jesus Jesus face
I made this for Flo Rida it's in 18
karat yellow gold and it has a 2,500
diamonds in this piece it's pretty heavy
I cannot wear it you know I have to
start going to the gym just to pay this
it's 1,500 grams he is actually wearing
it on a rope chain this is a wolf chin
he wears it on its goes 360 diamonds
going off all around I mean I went
clients tell me they want this I you
know I make I mean if they're willing to
pay for whatever you know I'll it's
business it this is a three-year-old a
man change I'm proud to be the inventor
of a herringbone chain like a for raw
damage and they used to call it and this
is actually a three row the first one I
made was for Nellie in 2007 for the BT
Awards Nellie called me a day and he
said like he wants like an old-school
herringbone those flag chains but he
wanted iced out so I was like how is
that possible like a hand born is 210
and how can we put diamonds in it and
nobody had done it yet it was a pretty
difficult task on the first one so it
now it's the signature
this is peace I just made for nav I made
it in the bag gates it has 15 carat
diamonds in it it's one of the new
pieces actually I just got it ready
yesterday I met nev through cash cash
from EXO he's been my friend and climbed
for like over 15 years I don't wanna
hurt nobody by Mimi but all my clients
are my favorite clients BBF big bag
family it's the same the one this guy
I'm making 20 pieces for him he's
getting all his friends pieces but he
got the most expensive one but the rest
of his all his friends he's getting them
initials like this
DBF big bag family and as you can see
the bag is right here on the top where
the chain goes to so I'm making these in
like three different sizes this one this
size there's one two sizes smaller than
this so this is the same would get money
back piece we talked about this is a
unicorn piece I just got it ready this
is for J Cortes
he's one of the hardest artists in
reggaeton at the moment and I got him a
nice Cuban link chain just one right
here to tone he's gonna wear this with
this just like that this was 25 pounds
plus the chain so it's all together the
setup is like 60 sometimes people just
buy the pendants and they put a rope
chain depending on their budget like Oh
Franco is like a plain gold chain
because obtain a nice diamond chain like
this will cost almost as much as of
these or more
this is also a logo it says s for strap
with baguettes I made this for one of my
clients he's a football player he plays
for the Eagles Philadelphia Eagles is
not a strap as you can see it says s for
strap that's his logo I've put baguettes
like I see like baguettes on the bezel
baguettes on the floor
it's a pretty nice sized piece this is a
gorilla it's a very expensive piece the
client he especially wanted to carry
diamonds in each eye so just these two
stones by itself were like $30,000 it's
two-tone white gold and rose gold you
can see in the tongue I had put red
rubies I really don't like working with
rubies but sometimes you have to and you
know for the detailing and stuff but I
really like working with Diamonds Rolex
paddocks ApS like all the different
watches this is the AP that's a break AP
like the other one I had the chandelier
one the rose gold one I showed you this
one is yellow gold yellow gold brick
actually this one the AP has stopped
making it they discontinued so it it
holds its values but I have done the
honeycomb setting on it
what's up you 40 what are you doing let
me see that grill the grill we did with
it recently did is hidden you know what
they say if it don't hit it in by Nick
[Music]
okay it's done right you seen this you
seen the chandelier yeah yeah all right
I'll catch you later boss to be in this
industry and doing this kind of this
amount of pieces and for 20 years it's
not an easy job I mean I have done
custom pieces which are like the top in
the hip-hop industry for for the last 20
years Complex magazine top five they
rated the top 50 custom thesis in
hip-hop in dust industry in like last
15-20 years and I had 10 pieces in the
top 50 and the first one was also done
by me it was the Ice Age piece we made
for my Jones how many times how many
diamonds it's a lot of diamonds like at
least 3 to 4 million